Peace and joy.
I trust you had a fruitful day.
I do not say happy.
I hope it has been a very happy day.
Namo tassa bhagavato arahato sambha sambodasa.
Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sammasambuddhasa.
Homage to the Buddha, the blessed noble and fully self-awakened one.
So these past few nights, we've met these various characters and treated mainly with the whole problem of dukkha, you know, suffering, pleasure, all that sort of stuff.
So I thought we would dig a little deeper and go to the first discourse in the book.
It's called The Root of All Things.
And it's one of the most difficult of discourses.
And Bhikkhu Bodhi has written a book on it, The Discourse on the Root of Existence, he's called it, which after this talk, I think it'll take two nights, you can take the study further.
This is really just an introduction to it.
And there are so many things that are spoken of in this discourse that it really is quite difficult to keep it all together.
So the first thing is to just see what it is that we're talking about.
So again, the Blessed One is at Ukkata.
So this is again in the northern country of Kosala, just beneath the Himalayas, it seems.
And he's at the Subaga Grove at the root of the Royal Salah tree.
That's a particular tree.
And there's a group of monks and nuns and other people around.
And he says, listen, attend closely to what I shall say.
So now this is the first paragraph.
And this paragraph is repeated with different subjects all the way through the discourse, or at least most of the discourse.
An untaught ordinary person who has no regard for noble ones and is unskilled and undisciplined in their dharma, who has no regard for true men, is an unskilled and undisciplined in their dharma, perceives earth as earth.
Having perceived earth as earth, he conceives himself as earth.
He conceives himself in earth.
He conceives himself apart from earth.
and he conceives himself, he conceives earth to be mine.
And he delights in it.
Why is that?
Because he's not fully understood it, I say.
Okay.
So now this earth is the earth element, so it's part of our body.
So remember, when the Buddha is talking, he makes it plain if he's talking about the world out there, he's talking about the world that we are personally experiencing, our own inner subjective phenomenal world.
And we've been through these basic concepts about the earth, the solidity of our body, the air, the movement, the water, the elasticity and the fire, the warmth or cold.
So that's how this opens.
Now, the first thing is to understand what he means by perception being
uh, perverted.
So these are called the perversions of, uh, perception, , the perversions of perception.
So the first, the first one is that whenever we talk about ourselves or part of our bodies, or even, even when we see something outside the body from our perspective, uh, we see it, we see what is impermanent as permanent.
Now, that doesn't strike true.
I mean, we know that all things change, but here, impermanent, of course, is the idea of it being moment to moment, whereas for us, everything flows.
So even when we go to bed at night, we don't presume that tomorrow we'll be dead.
There's a sort of presumption that life will carry on.
We perceive our lives as continuing, you see, and that's the perversion.
We don't see it as it really is, which is, of course, arising and passing away very momentarily.
And what is painful, we see as pleasurable.
And this is always referring to this indulgence, right?
Not to pleasure itself, but how we relate to it.
That's the perversion.
And as we know,
indulgence, attachment, dependency brings sorrow in its wake.
Yeah, the grief of loss, anxiety that you might lose it, frustration when you don't get it, and so on.
And of course, there's what is not self we perceive as self.
So this is how we see ourselves, how we experience ourselves as a person, as one integral total person.
Whereas we know we're made up of all sorts of stuff.
And finally, the foul as beautiful.
So here you've got to be careful.
We're not talking about beauty as an aesthetic appreciation, but more the body itself.
Remember, beauty is only skin deep.
So if you take the skin off somebody, it isn't particularly nice.
So these are the four perversions that we have.
Now, when we perceive something, this is the moment when we have that first image, the first photocopy in the mind.
And it's from that first photocopy that other photocopies are added.
And this is the process of a perception slowly building up into a concept.
Now, if you take just a very simple thing like an orange, the first time we saw an orange, we would have perceived it as an object, would have tasted it, et cetera, et cetera.
But the more we ate oranges, the more we found out about oranges, we found they come in all sorts of sizes, in all sorts of sweetness and bitterness.
And then we have this grand concept of an orange.
So that word, which is only a sound, of course, other languages have different words for an orange.
That's only a sound.
But for us, it holds our experience of oranges, which includes, of course, marmalade, without which very difficult to live.
OK, so when we're conceiving here, there are three things involved which distort the process of conception.
first of all there's the wrong view the wrong understanding which is included in these uh perversions that we've talked about uh the perversion of of um of uh perception right it's all there as it were within that concept then of course there's the emotional commitment to it
If you think about politics, if you think about religion, people get very attached to their concepts about what life is about, what politics should be about, etc, etc.
That attachment is a real heart commitment.
And of course, people will die for their beliefs.
And then there's mana, which is the conceit.
So this conceit is always three part.
I am better than the rest of everybody else.
I'm worse than, it's an inverted conceit.
And of course, this one which is more subtle, I'm the same as.
So remember this, I am the same as is of a group.
So it's the group which says, we are better than, we are worse than.
So that underlies, as it were, all concepts.
You can see this in the present day discussion and demonstrations all around racism.
So every tribe, every nation always has strangers.
It always has aliens, always has the other.
And there's always special names for those people.
And that perception,
you know, is enforced at the beginning as a simple perception, but then it grows as a concept.
And really, of course, the way to overcome prejudice is, of course, to begin to see the more underlying connection that lies between human beings and that realizing that culture, color of skin and all that sort of stuff is, you know, really quite superficial.
Okay, so we've got these two things now.
We've got the original distortions of perception when we see something, right?
So that includes what is impermanent as permanent, what is painful as pleasant, what is not self as a self, and what is really not very pleasant as beautiful, okay?
And then when we're developing this
conception there is this underlying misunderstanding underlying wrong view there's an attachment to what I believe I know and there's that conceit with the eye so now having done that he points out these four different relationships that we can have with things so these things are anything that we're experiencing
So he says now there are four types of experiences, and I suppose the easiest one would be, let me see, where am I?
Yes, perceive.
See, he's got a whole category of things where this perception is wrong.
So it's to perceive earth as earth, to believe I am the body, shall we say,
To conceive, sorry, to perceive Earth as Earth is to see the body as body, but then there's this relationship.
He perceives Earth as himself, so that's the identity.
He perceives himself in Earth, so there's me, but I'm in the body.
It's two separate things, but I'm in the body.
There's me as separate from the body, you know,
Like, although the body's there, I'm sort of outside it.
And there's me as mine.
There's the body as mine, which is that possessiveness.
And because of this, the person delights in earth, delights in the body.
Okay?
So with that basis, one is always seeking happiness.
And that's the process of attachment.
So you can see that these delusions go deep.
So he says this for the four elements.
And then he talks about beings, right?
Conceives himself in beings, part of beings.
And he conceives himself as being separate from beings, as being within the community of beings.
And he delights and he owns them.
He says, these are, I belong to these beings.
and he delights in being a being.
And then he goes through a whole section of different types of gods, different types of heavenly gods.
And then he goes through the four Arupa Jhāna, the four formless Jhāna states, the four highest Jhāna states.
And then he goes through the senses, so what he perceives the seen as seen.
whatever object we see, we perceive it, that's the first, we've just talked about the orange, and the heard, and then he goes on about the sensed, which includes the smelt, the tasted and the touched, and then there's the cognised, so what is known, and he conceives himself in what is known.
That's more to do with knowledge.
So this whole discourse is really about the perceptual, conceptual process that we have.
When it comes to dukkha, it's all about the heart, the emotion, the attachments.
But here you can see these things are based on the way that we look at things, on the way that we relate to things.
And there's two here which talk about unity, where he's talking about the mind in a state of concentration.
But it's seemingly it has an effect on our philosophy, where we think everything is based on one particular concept.
So, for instance, a monistic religion believing in one God that underrules everything.
And then there's one with diversity, which is the ordinary mind, which leads us to believe that there are more than one thing which subsists underneath our lives and the universe.
So it produces different types of philosophies.
Monism and pluralism, it goes as far as that, you see.
And then there's the perceives all as all, within the all and separate from the all.
And I belong to the all or the all belongs to me.
All these relationships about the way we relate to everything that we experience.
And that seemingly leads us to pantheism, that everything is God and a more sort of romantic idea of being the all, being part of the all.
And then finally there's Nibbāna, but this Nibbāna that he's talking about is the mistaken Nibbānas, thinking that sensual pleasure is Nibbāna, all these beautiful mental states caused by absorptions are Nibbāna.
And so it goes even to that level.
Okay, so this is the, that's the discourse in, shall we say, in a very brief way.
And for those who...
who want to take it deeper, Bhikkhu Bodhi has written a book on it, The Discourse on the Root of Existence.
I've read it years ago, and I put it on my list of books to read again, probably next life.
So, if we go through that again, if you can sort of handle these different lists.
So, the first list is the way we perceive.
impermanent we see what is actually impermanent as permanent right so that's that sense of continuing sense of continuation especially the sense of self what is painful is pleasant so that's the indulgence business we don't see the consequences uh sometimes and the not self as self so this feeling that i am me this sense of self that we have in us something that's that is always continuous a sense of presence
uh which is of course mind made and of course seeing what is it's translated as foul or um something that is not beautiful but we see it as beautiful so this would be something like the human body which as i say you take the skin off it's not very nice at all so those are your four perversions of perception right so that they're always there you see it's only when you reach these paths and fruits
These attainments that these are beginning to be undermined and of course, they've all gone once we've attained full liberation So there's a whole conceptual cleansing As well.
So remember there's this is this twofold things.
There's the heart being cleansed of its angers and and Excitements and indulgences, but there's also the mind The way we think has to be also corrected
And then when we conceive something, when we have a conception, it's always involved with some sort of wrong understanding somewhere, some attachment to it.
So there's the heart's involvement.
And of course, the sense of conceit, better than, more clear than, et cetera, et cetera.
And then finally, when we come to the actual object that we are relating to, and of course, this includes persons when we're including persons, but really it's to do with, in terms of our spiritual awakening, it's to do with ourselves, a sense of identity.
See, I am me, a sense of locality.
I am in me.
I and the me are separate, but I'm in it.
A sense of distance.
um that i i'm in it but i'm not the same at all and the sense of being that i have so you know like when we say i've got a bad knee or something so those are your four relationships so you can see it's multi-layered you know the way that we build up the world around us and once this uh we've got these concepts then you have what this proliferation this papantia
All right.
And that's where the mind creates these wonderful stories.
At best, we have art and philosophy and maths maybe.
So all these all these layers, one on top of the other, and it produces our philosophies.
So, as I say, if you want to go into this more deeply, then Kubota has written the book on it.
But what I shall do is return to this tomorrow and just and just give the finishing paragraphs to it.
where the Buddha talks about the different types of Arahats and himself.
So that's quite a discourse.
It is the hardest one in the book because Bodhi actually advises you not to read this one and to go on to the second one and keep going and then just come back to it at some time when we've collected some of these concepts.
So we have done this stuff before, but here it's all coming together to show us how we build up our concept of the world, our relationship.
It's all about relationship, remember.
It's all about the way we relate both to ourselves and to others.
Ethics.
Very good.
So I can only hope that hasn't created even more confusion.
but has been inspirational and that it will force you to continue your practice until you are liberated sooner rather than later.
So we can do some practice.